[Music]
uh since we are since we are talking
about media we have to we have to point
out this video from project veritas no
oh no i don't know have you seen this
i don't know it's good right i saw
bits of it no one ever says that those
things out loud but it's obvious here's
some blades
leads at least twitter permanently
suspended his account
after he exposed oh no he's not doing
dance moves too is he i
okay i didn't look i want to make
something clear here i like a lot of the
work that project veritas does they've
uncovered a lot of [ __ ] and agreed
i think it's great this is still um
terrible why are you doing this this is
unacceptable why are you doing this
who told you this was a good idea why
are you doing it it's almost like maybe
somebody took a payoff
because this is by the way this is
there's two roads that this
what we do for a living there's two
roads and how it ends
you stay authentic forever and you die
poor
or you eventually take the money you
take the buy out
and then you start acting irrationally
cringe
it happened with nick fuentes it
happened it's now happening with project
veritas happened with milo happened with
all these people they all end up taking
the money and they all end up acting
really cringe crenshaw's another one
[ __ ] after he exposed hypocrisy and
fraud
at cnn veritas a very controversial
conservative
promoting misinformation that the
footage from project veritas was part of
the according to stanford research
coordinated i can't i can't mike i'm
getting i'm getting douche chills oh no
can i just say this and i this is gonna
piss some people off today
and please look i know the audience is
about to get very mad at me
i'm glad biden won i'm glad he won
i'm look i am glad the left is putting a
[ __ ] foot up
our ass because you know what some of
you need it
some of you guys need a big [ __ ]
leftist pick up your [ __ ] asses it's
what you need
maybe it'll snap some of you out of it
maybe you'll wake up maybe some of you
will realize
that the dan crenshaws and the charlie
kirks and this [ __ ] and crowd are
doing dance videos
ain't winning no culture wars i'm glad
biden won we deserve this
disinformation disinformation should the
new york times were definitely
veritas just won a major victory in that
case come to you and offer you a hundred
million dollars you're not gonna settle
that would tell them to go to hell
[Music]
all of us
this isn't
the problem with this man and this is
what you [ __ ] [ __ ]
every time you guys are strapped for
cash
every time you guys are strapped for a
couple bucks
you start pandering to those boomers
again man you keep trying to squeeze
these boomers out of their [ __ ]
social security money
because you i'm sure old james hit had
because you notice the timing right it's
always right after a twitter suspension
it's always right after
social media [ __ ] them on some level or
they lose their patreon again
and then they always come out with like
they always just go full cringe
mike he has a sledgehammer in his hand
is he gonna do what i think he's gonna
do
i hope i hope he's going to
shove it up his own asteroids i hope
he's going to
i hope he's going to cover it in tar
and then cover the tar in [ __ ] thumb
tacks
and then i hope he's going to sit on
that thing you do look here's the thing
project veritas does a lot of good work
and i've said that right
wouldn't you want to maintain an error
of journalism
like be like hey you know man they're
taking us down and that's [ __ ]
because we're exposing them
and whatever but instead you do a dance
video at the end of the day
i love to you know
i i try to avoid having faith in people
like this because at the end of the day
sure see as as project veritas have
james o'keefe done some great work
yes have they done some good things yes
but their their desire for justice and
truth
just like everybody else in this world
will always come secondary
to paying the bills and paying all of
those employees that are in this video
so i understand that
so you know we you look at some stuff
somebody does and you go wow man that's
great i hope he always
hits all all cylinders like that but
he's got money troubles and he's trying
to get that crowd or mug money that's
what's going on here and it's
it's all because they want money
yes do they do do i am i saying that
james o'keefe
is a piece of [ __ ] sellout who doesn't
care about the troop no
i think he cares about the truth i think
he cares about doing the right thing
but for every human being on this planet
almost every human being
doing what's right versus feeding
themselves and paying their bills i'm
sorry
but doing what's right will always come
second to that
that's how these people are man they all
have businesses to run
down because they confronted a facebook
executive take a video like that down it
would be due to
a documenting concern i can show you a
video of cnn doing the exact same thing
twitter made
factual statements about our clients
[Music]
this music video is making me root for
jack dorsey
i'm on team jack dorsey if here okay so
look man
people are on their sides right people
are right wingers who are left-wingers
and i get that and i get it but the
people in the middle the people you want
to win over right
and a lot of that's probably the younger
generation coming up too those are the
people you want to win over right that's
the people you want to go
you don't want these people to control
your life you don't want to be you don't
want to be [ __ ] communist control you
whatever
for anybody that's getting mad that
we're making fun of this
and we should be not that anybody is in
the chat i'm just saying for anyone that
might be listening later
that's making that's getting mad because
we're making fun of this if don lemon
was doing this very thing
and we were making fun of him everybody
would be [ __ ] doing jumping jacks
laughing their [ __ ] this guy's a [ __ ]
i don't care your political belief
the moment you do this you look like a
[ __ ] fool
you look like a fool yeah you and you
know what really the reason that
i want to make fun of this even more is
it bums me out it bums me out
because this guy actually did does i'll
even say does
real journalism what journalists used to
do right
which was like no no i'm going to get
this story i don't give a [ __ ] what you
say
i'm going to record people saying that
they're going to [ __ ] with the election
i'm going to record
by uh burning people saying they want to
burn the cities down i'm going to
[ __ ] take them down
and you're right and that's the right
thing to do and then you do this
do you not have any friends
do you not have any friends that told
you
you're in a good position right now even
though you got banned from twitter that
sucks
but you're in a good position because a
lot of people are on your side because i
think you're that they're
that you're real journalists you're a
real journalist and you're doing what
all these other [ __ ] and even people
fox news
and newsmax you're doing what all these
other [ __ ] aren't doing and you decide
after [ __ ] being the hero of being
the martyr after them taking you down
for telling the truth
you decide what i need to do is do a
dance video
this isn't crowder but that's the
problem royce is that
he does have friends those friends are
stephen crowder those friends are mike
cernovich those friends are jack
pasobiak
i mean we can pretend like
you know that they their hands aren't
involved in this but
you know as much as james o'keefe does
do good work
he's still deeply tied to a lot of these
pieces of [ __ ]
what is he in ernest they are not real
friends
you know these are all people look this
is what i've called for some time now
this is the uh tom mcdonald effect
or the mag effect where you just
join a thing and then everybody likes
you despite how bad you are because
you're pushing a certain angle
but yeah he does he has friends royce
but they're not good friends
right they're posobiacs and they're
cernovich's and they're going yeah man
that's
awesome yeah dude you should make that
music video man be so cool
they're all out of touch they all turned
this
so-called culture war into a [ __ ]
flea market they did it
years ago we sat here and we've been
bitching for four [ __ ] years
and having everybody call us secret
leftists and calling us subversive
all these guys are just trying to cut
down the right you and i have been
watching for four years
while every one of these people has fist
[ __ ] the culture war dry of
any available money and these people
didn't
these aren't people that had like real
like line in the sand gofundme so we
could fight back
they bought houses they bought cars they
bought trips they bought hotel rooms
they threw parties
it's what they did for four years and
they just blew everybody's money
that's what it is and now now old keith
has has put himself in a position where
he probably has a staff he's got to pay
people he needs money
he's probably running on a thin budget
here he probably gets a lot of support
from the posobia x and the cernovich's
and those crowds these tim pools and
these crowders and
everybody's just such a great
businessman
but if you think any of these guys ever
gave a [ __ ]
they might have gave a [ __ ] a little bit
but again
you can be like i want to do the right
thing i want to fight on the right side
of history
but i also technically i want to buy a
house
and then i also want to do this that's
life can i tell you can you cause i'm
just i'm thinking of like reporter like
there's there's some journalists that i
respect you know what
here's someone i respect john stossel
john stossel
even when he was on abc and he was on
2020 i respected him because
he was docile yeah he would he would go
into [ __ ] businesses that were
[ __ ] people like i used
that was the best john stossel he would
go into business that were [ __ ]
people that were trying to you know hurt
people
he would go in there and go yo what
you're doing is wrong he'd go undercover
he would do all that stuff
and i respected that can you imagine a
john stossel coming out with a
dancing music video like i'm really
thinking think of journalism respect
actually just want nothing more than
that now
to be honest can dr d slap him in both
ears
i think he did didn't hit him twice
[Music]
i think is a despicable person
the judge said and your reporters
interject their opinions it stands to
reason you should inform your reader
they injected their opinions in news
articles
new york times is tripping over
themselves now he's going to be suing
twitter he's not backing another
defamation lawsuit
this time against
too many people let too much cringe [ __ ]
slide for too long and you all did it in
the name of not punching right
well maybe if some more people had
punched right
we could have knocked out some of this
[ __ ] before it happened
but you didn't you only wanted to shame
the other side
you never wanted to shame the people on
your side that was making your side look
bad
which to me is the prince the main
principles make sure your own backyard
is clean
make sure your own people are acting up
to the standards that you're telling the
other side they need to live
up to but the truth is nobody on the
right ever lived up to any of these
standards like
it you know what it turns out it turns
out we're [ __ ] cringing
too of course i think we're all cringing
and hypocrites also hypocrites when it
came to censorship
hypocrites when it came to playing dirty
hypocrites oh yeah let's
let's just do what the left does and
throw it back at him
no but that's what make that i thought
what separated us was our principles
we threw all of our principles out the
window we started trying to beat the
left at their own game
and we [ __ ] lost how does that feel
so now you don't have any you don't you
don't even now have your principles to
fall back on
now you're just a loser who also cheated
imagine cheating and then also losing
and we threw everything the we should we
should report all the leftist accounts
that also do the things that say the
things we don't like
and all this other [ __ ] and we all just
find we let
[ __ ] like i know this is just coming out
now but with milo
and with [ __ ] posobiac and cernovich
and gavin and all and we just repeatedly
allowed
[ __ ] behavior after [ __ ] behavior and we
were like it's okay
man because he's fighting on our side
and we kept telling ourselves
that corny ass steven crowder dance
videos we're gonna get the zoomers
you're [ __ ] delusional